and then you know you get to a certain
age and you start discovering things
about yourself and you probably
shouldn't be bunking with your younger
brother
i'm comedian ryan sickler and this is my
stepson derek crawford while we were on
quarantine class might have been out but
school was still in session all right
let's go
very serious business you have lives
especially this one
in your literal hands and feet
it was like an old country road and it
had an awesome hill to jump jumping them
yeah dude we jumped the [ __ ] out of them
oh no hold on
look at the aloha
just heavy on the brakes i mean jesus
christ stay in your lane you're hurting
jerky with turns this is learner's
permit
all right
all right so you want to get over when
you can look there's a car in our blind
spot
and take that local access road yeah
wait till this car passes hit to hit
your brakes
all right he's getting behind you so go
ahead and move over but watch what's
going on ahead of you too
and then you can make a right down rodeo
and we'll go just go down these streets
me and my two brothers shared a bedroom
they were in bunk beds i was in a twin
bed next to them that's the closest i've
ever had in my own room
so we move into this apartment because
all we had was our friends our mom left
us alone in this apartment every night
she'd come home on sundays do laundry
maybe maybe once in a while come by and
grab something but we just took care of
ourselves and lived in that place then
when we graduated she kicked us out on
july 4th
1991 and on july 3rd
1991 we threw the biggest party
that [ __ ] county had ever seen
in a long time i mean we went to school
college orientations and we would just
tell people party tonight they're party
party tell everybody they can't we
didn't even know these people they came
from everywhere so our mom shows up
she's like what the hell is going on we
had a canopy over the beer in case it
rained we pulled the cords and made it
slap against her we had a bouncer gave
him free beer all night he was mr
maryland lived across the street the
girls next door they came over this is
beverly up here this one not this one
the next one okay that's what okay i got
this one the next next one there we go
this one
this now it's this nose thank you
we've been saying the whole time the
state police show up because the
neighbors some of the neighbors oh yeah
state police not just the local no state
police maryland suicide doors all right
brakes brakes brakes brakes what the
hell are you doing i'm breaking watch
these people you're looking at that
green light over there all night
and we had everybody parked at the
parking lot of the carnival because the
firehouse was right by us and we knew
how they parked so we had people over
there directing people in putting them
in spaces and everything it was full it
looked like the carnival was there it's
how many people in this apartment my mom
had let the people moving in put their
like little camper a towing camper on
the little because it was a little
gravel driveway on the property like
right there
and our friend got up on top of it
kicked the skylight off of it wasted
just peed all in it just peed in it i
mean we were it was crazy so the cops
show up state troopers like first of all
whose party is this he's like is this
yours and i was like it just depends on
what you're gonna say he's like do you
live here and i go i do live here he
goes who the hell's in charge of the
parking over at the fire department i
was like that would be me he's like let
me tell you something son that's the
best parking job
i've ever seen for a party or anything
and if you guys want to work the
carnival this summer we can talk but
right now you got a lot of underage kids
here drinking you got to clear them out
of here and i said well will you please
use your bull horn and
announce it he goes nope and i go okay
no one's going to leave he goes okay
so i go hey everybody state trooper here
says we're all underage no more drinking
we got to wrap it up and get out of here
and like two nerds ran you know what i
mean
everybody else just stood there and he
goes if i come back and circle through
and there's still people here you guys
are going to jail and i said
you heard him everybody and everybody
just stayed and he left and he never
came back
i mean instead of a big house a big-ass
house like these i'd rather have a
modest house with land
i'm telling you i want to
move to like corona and get one of those
houses out there like just where all i'm
talking about like your grandparents
living in georgia like oh like a modest
house with land and a
a four-wheeler or some polaris something
i can ride around on where i can
throw crab traps out in the salt water
and
let them sit there all week and get fat
on my bait until saturday and sunday
have a crab feast every week go fishing
when i want
that's all my brother's doing it right
go through this light go go go go i mean
that was red it wasn't red yellow means
clear the intersection yellow means well
that there was everybody else was
stopped and you had time to get through
there so if you have time get through
there as long as it's completely safe
you didn't have to hit the gas or
anything that's that's a safe through
and get these guys hit the gas
hey
[Music]
[Music]
you